good morning Hank it's Tuesday March 17
2021 it's question Tuesday the day that
I answer real questions from real
nerdfighters let's get right to it can
you start the video by telling Hank the
wrong day sure is it Kouga Schiff a 17
year old girl goes out with a 15 year
old guy
when did kouga's happen how is Kouga
sure thing when French the llama
continues inexplicably not to be a thing
anyway that does not strike me as Kouga
[ __ ] strikes me as completely normal can
you speak Dutch no I keep trying to get
through a whole interaction with someone
only speaking Dutch so I'll be like aim
deer danke Ville and the person will be
like I'm sorry I don't understand what
you're saying do you want beer what's
the most archaic thing you know how to
do pretty good at turning magazine pages
why didn't you show the good morning
Hank it's Wednesday from Plainfield
Indiana there's something wrong with my
phone and I can't get videos from my
phone into my computer like insert
Plainfield video yet it didn't work why
are pirates pirates because they failed
out of ninja University who the eff is
Hank Hank is a trans-neptunian object
27% more massive than Pluto Hank was
originally named Xena after the warrior
princess but then the scientific team
that discovered Hank decided that Hank
should be named something more astronomy
ish like Hank why haven't you done
peanut butter face in a long time I
disagree with your premise this guy is
really affecting my vision oh yeah
that's much better
Oh peanut butter face what were some of
the original titles of your books oh I'm
glad I did peanut butter face before I
answered the literary question they were
always really pretentious like more
light than heat or an imperial
affliction both of which it occurs to me
would be really good with the in your
pants rule can you explain the in your
pants thing yeah our friend Maureen
Johnson discovered that book titles are
funnier when you add in your pants to
the end of them like the nature of
monsters in your pants for the pleasures
and sorrows of work in your pants or a
la Festa if Anita in your pants if Henry
had been a girl what would you have
named her the Yeti and I agreed in
advance that if the baby was a boy he
would be named Henry and if the baby was
a girl she would be named bubbles the
nerd fighting lady baby are we were
gonna find out the lie from the April
Fool's video yeah the lie was that there
was no VY House Amsterdam it's great the
peanut butters delicious has Helen Hunt
heard the Helen Hunt song yet no but did
you know that Helen Hunt has a Twitter
what happens inside a black hole we
don't really know but scientists believe
that being inside of a black hole is a
great way to feel special because you're
guaranteed
come a singularity anyone no singularity
jokes it's physics it's funny cuz it's
theoretical can you restock the dftba
shirts please bing-bing-bing-bing done
all these years are back in stock at
dftba.com your independently-owned uncor
prett deliciously disorganized friendly
neighborhood I Taylor what are the marks
on your arm their birthmarks get used to
them because they're gonna be around the
rest of my life unless my arm gets cut
off how do you feel about Hank being a
meme it's not like it's a competition or
anything but just to be clear I am also
a meme where is Willie is he there with
you in Amsterdam no Willie staying with
the yetis aunt and uncle who he likes
far better than he likes me Willie has
regarded me with suspicion ever since I
revealed to you his inability to achieve
a full tale rection he may not like me
very much but I bet he wishes he was
here right now what is Willie's middle
name I guess technically it's Wilson
bubbles the nerdfighting puppy Roberts
what are we doing for Hank Oh DeMaio
there is a link in the doobly-doo on
this very topic please click on it right
now unless you are Hank Hank if you
click on that link I will cut off your
fingers probably not that's an
exaggeration but there will be serious
consequences there won't be any
consequences but don't click on the link
shouldn't you be writing your new book
right now yes yes I should Hank I'll see
you on Monday